aliens are just a cooked up narrative by
modernists trying to cover up the
metaphysical reality of angels and
people they not challenging us too much
on this
one and you're going to say I'm just
trying to see if you've come to your
senses
yet are they saved well I don't know
what their salvation history is is there
a fourth person of the Trinity no who's
like a martian no no no so but you're
the one just quoting CS Lewis a second
ago we don't that's gets me into trouble
I know so you know we don't know I I
can't that's that's a question I can't
answer but just because I can't answer
the question doesn't mean that like just
because it's incomprehensible for me
like what would the Salvation history be
of a of a intell would they even be
fallen yeah would they I think it's I
think at a minimum it would seem to me
that any rational species in the
universe would have had the same
opportunity to make a choice as we did
and if it's a real Choice then you could
have unfallen species yeah I don't see
why although I don't even onto that like
a little baby doesn't have the choice